m
les membres du conseil départemental des
jeunes se sont rendus à la maison de
l'amitié à saint paul une maison dédiée
aux sans abri et aux familles
ponctuellement dans le besoin depuis
janvier en a heureusement donc tout ce
qui est humain tu repars l'âge c'est
tout nero bas depuis manas c'est le
repas du midi le petit déjeuner et les
jeunes du conseil départemental ne sont
pas venus les mains vides
ils ont souhaité apporter des denrées
alimentaires afin d'aider les plus
démunis durant une journée ces jeunes
ont pu partager le quotidien des sans
abri
une action de solidarité qu'ils ont eux
mêmes décidé de mettre en place
on a rencontré la maison de
l'association la maison de l'amitié qui
a été tout à fait partie prenante pour
mener cette action avec nous et donc on
a eu une séance de travail avec les
jeunes et donc on a décidé de faire une
action pour que les sans abri voit que
les jeunes pensent à eux c'était surtout
le message qu'ils veulent faire passer
que bay les jeunes sont là que les
jeunes sont à l'arrêt à leur écoute
les jeunes ont offert aux sans abri un
petit déjeuner puis tous se sont mis aux
fourneaux pour préparer le repas du midi
qu'ils partageront avec les sans abri
emmène à une action comme celle ci les
jeunes du conseil départemental en la
sensation d'aidé d'aller vers les autres
et de se sentir utile alors c'est
important parce que
c'est un sujet qui quand même touche
toute l'île et que nous on commence à
rentrer dans l'âge adulte donc on sait
très bien qu'il ya des difficultés
souvent bas que ce soit dans l'habitat
au travail et que ça peut toucher
n'importe qui et n'importe quand mais
c'est intéressant parce que c'est un
sujet d'actualité il y en a plus en plus
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que je trouve
que en tant que jeune on n'est pas assez
mobilisés pour ça alors apporter un peu
de joie de vivre à ces personnes c'est
important pour vraiment nous ça nous
apporte un moment de convivialité fin on
connaît pas ces personnes ça nous permet
de faire connaissance avec elle on
apprend ce qu'ils vivent ils me
racontent leur histoire c'est vraiment
intéressante chiant ça ça nous fait
beaucoup plaisir d'être là aujourd'hui
ça les apporte un petit moment de
plaisir un petit moment de bonheur
et ils n'ont pas la chance d'avoir des
jeunes comme ça avec eux présents tous
les jours et si on peut apporter sa
juste en venant et emmené en apportant
quelque chose de pur pour manger ça fait
plaisir quoi on se sent important et on
donne de notre personne est juste voir
leur sourire sur le visage ne feront le
plus grand plaisir pour les sans abri la
maison de l'amitié est une aide
indispensable qui leur permit de
s'alimenter quand ils n'ont plus les
moyens de le faire la présence du
conseil départemental des jeunes est un
vrai bonheur pour eux une journée qui
leur permet de sortir de leur isolement
de partage et d'échangé et de passer un
moment convivial bon pour moi c'est
important mais je trouve c'est bien et
c'est très bien pour tous les ans vient
aussi ici et manger le midi
bon c'est un bon c'est ce qu'ils font et
envers nous et moi je trouve ça très
très bon bonus un plaisir sain joie de
prendre un petit déjeuner et dîner
l'après midi et c'est bien pour nous
tous